aquí tenemos una imagen del planeta
lubri con 6
este es el planeta lubri con 6 y es un
planeta muy especial porque está hecho
de un elemento que aún no descubren
llamado lu bricio el elemento se llama
luz bricio y este es especial porque si
algo se desliza sobre él no
experimentará fricción alguna ok
entonces este planeta está digamos en el
espacio exterior muy exterior en el
espacio exterior muy lejano y se
encuentra a la deriva además de todo es
un planeta muy viejo y es tan viejo que
ni siquiera existe ya la estrella
digamos la estrella alrededor del cual
orbitaba esa estrella ya murió además de
todo es un planeta que ya no tiene
atmósfera es decir alrededor de este
planeta lo único que hay es el vacío ok
ahora lo que tiene de interesante de
este elemento loo bricio es que tiene la
propiedad que ya dijimos de que si algo
se desliza sobre él no experimenta
fricción alguna entonces quiere decir
que si yo tengo aquí por ejemplo una
vista lateral de la superficie de este
planeta y digamos que yo tengo un nose
digamos un bloque un tabique quizás algo
así
ok este bloque si yo o más bien si este
bloque se empieza a deslizar hacia la
derecha este bloque no va a experimentar
fricción y entonces se va a mover y no
se va a ver afectado por la fricción ok
entonces una última una última hipótesis
que tenemos de este planeta lúbrico es
que es una esfera perfecta resulta que
esta es una esfera perfecta
y entonces con todo esto que ya hemos
dicho que está hecho de este elemento
especial llamado lu bricio que es una
esfera perfecta que no tiene atmósfera
está a la deriva y que ya es un planeta
tan viejo que no tiene solo alrededor
del cual la órbita la pregunta es la
siguiente digamos que tenemos un bloque
en donde por alguna razón bizarra hay un
calcetín congelado en este bloque
ok digamos que hay un calcetín que por
alguna razón no sabemos cuál llegó ahí y
ese bloque se empieza a mover sobre la
superficie del planeta lubri con digamos
a una velocidad de un kilómetro por hora
ok entonces se mueve a un kilómetro por
hora la pregunta es qué pasará con el
calcetín a lo largo del tiempo y te
invito a que hagas una pausa y
reflexiones un poco qué es lo que va a
pasar con él
así que suponiendo que ya te tomaste un
tiempo para reflexionar para poder
responder esa pregunta necesitamos
pensar en todas las fuerzas que están
actuando sobre este cubo congelado en
dónde se encuentra nuestro cannes
calcetín ok entonces vamos a descomponer
en todas las fuerzas que se nos puedan
ocurrir primero vamos a hablar de las
fuerzas radiales es decir si yo tengo
que mi calcetín se encuentra sobre la
superficie de este planeta y lleva a
esta velocidad digamos que se está
moviendo a lo largo del ecuador que se
mueve a lo largo del ecuador vamos a ver
qué pasa con las fuerzas radiales es
decir las que van de este cuerpo al
centro del planeta es decir las que van
hacia abajo si lo vemos en esta
perspectiva y sabemos que según la masa
que tenga este bloque pues tendrá una
fuerza de gravedad que atrae a este
cuerpo al centro de este planeta verdad
a esta fuerza vamos a llamarle fg fg que
es fuerza de gravedad muy bien
además de esto vamos a tener bueno por
supuesto como este bloque se mueve sobre
la superficie del planeta y no sale
volando ni se va hacia el centro de la
tierra eso quiere decir que hay una
fuerza normal hay una fuerza normal
una fuerza normal que también actúa
sobre este cuerpo y que de hecho es a
partir de la superficie de verdad además
bueno esos esas son esencialmente todas
las fuerzas radiales que tenemos la
pregunta es bueno bueno alguna pregunta
que podría ser natural es si esta fuerza
normal es igual a la fuerza de gravedad
y realmente lo es pero vamos a
discutirlo en otro vídeo ok entonces
ahora pensemos en las fuerzas
tangenciales es decir las que se mueven
hacia la derecha oa la izquierda y uno
podría pensar que a lo mejor aquí habría
fricción pero dijimos que este elemento
el lúbrico no tiene fricción ok esto se
mueve sin fricción entonces no hay
ninguna otra fuerza que pueda imprimirse
la a este objeto así que como no hay
aire no hay fricción no hay nada
entonces continuará moviéndose a un
kilómetro por hora por el resto de los
tiempos dadas las hipótesis que hicimos